Một mỗi hai giờ đêm, bún biển với khá lòng cách bờ chúng mười kê số vẫn giúp xa ngành đèn.
Rất một chăm tổ sôn lù chúng lại, con hàng chăm cả mộ trên sĩ của các lượng lượng công an,
con đổi, nào hành động hết công sớt để ngành trọng tình kìm những lạng đèn còn mất tích trong bộ lợi tầu với sang nằm tắm.
Cùng với việc tìm kìm xung quanh khu vực tầu vì lạng.
Bà tầu cứ hộ cơ lớn, có chăm vị cân cầu cũng được vi động để lất nội con tầu này.
Hành chăm tình bị linh tục được chuyển đến, nhằm chình thay còn tắt thứ hộ cứng nạn nhận trong đó của những hành quan.
Cùng vì động hơn 2 mi chính sĩ người nhá của lượng đặc cơ nước một hai sâu.
Bởi đây đủ trà thêm bị, những bình khí phó rành rấu vị chỉ, đàn pin giới nước, nhằm lạng sâu và trong khoảng tầu và các vùng biển xung quanh để tìm kìm nạn nhận.
Mà phó pháp sử dụng người nháy lạng sâu xuống dưới thân tầu, bộ dây cáp và những vị chỉ tríu lực.
Sau đó sẽ giúp cân cầu và tời công sốt lớn để lất nước thân tầu đến một dở băm phó sáng này, tầu vị xanh năm tắm đặc được lạc lạc theo chờ thẳng đứng.
Mún tì thể nạn nhận được tìm thấy trên đền cơ viên điều khẹn của con tầu trong đó có tình chờ.
Tình đến năm dở sáng này, lực lượng trưng năng đặc tư sống được mọi người.
Tình kiếm thi thể của 3 mấy tạm người và đăng tiếp tục tình kiếm những người mất tích.
Tầu viên xanh năm tắm sau khi nổi hành toàn, nực lạng rất bệ bờ để chẳng chùm báo.
Và tiếp tục điều tra làm gió vụ tài nạn nhìn trọng này.
Dạy lạng đà bán khoảng dí vình hà lòng cho biết, sáng này sau khi được bơm lước trong khoảng dân ngoài.
Tầu giúp lực vị xanh năm tắm đã được cơ quan chức năng lạy rất về khu vực nhá mấy đống tầu hà lòng để kìm tra.